well first of all what i need you to do
is tell me what it was like for you to
meet jared because you told me at the
press day you had not met you
oh i like him so much
he's so sweet and he's really playful
and um and we just make each other laugh
it's just really it's we have a very
gentle thing i saw that on the carpet
you were like laughing a little bit it
seems like you guys really i mean what
an experience you had making this show
together and having that intimacy
oh yeah yeah and to just you know um
the thing about what the little that i
know about jared is that he cares about
what he does body and soul so much and
i'm the same way so to be able to
connect like that over a shared passion
something that we both really love
giving ourselves fully to in a way that
i get it it's unusual
um it was really really special i feel
really lucky that he was my partner in
this
i know he went very method but i did
hear you committed to raw vegan for this
one i didn't commit to it i just found
myself there by the end i just yeah yeah
it was that kind of took a hold i mean i
love it
until i don't
know you want a burger in front exactly
look amazing how do you feel thank you
very much i feel pretty i don't know i
don't tend to feel on these things but
um but i'll tell you how i feel is so
lucky so crazy lucky i'm grateful to be
here i'm grateful for this opportunity
and i'm really grateful for the team
that got me all
looking like this so i so so yeah i feel
very grateful stunning stunning um i
heard that you did maybe make him break
once with the father-son house of god
yeah
uh no no i he never broke
never broke not even one snot for any
second not even for that one even his
that was part of the one of the most
impressive impressive things about it
was uh as i mentioned split in three
like a horror crux and then came back
together and then responded as adam are
you a harry potter person who isn't i
mean what house are you
i okay according to the internet
quiz i am gryffindor
but
i don't know i wonder if i'm not a
hufflepuff
hufflepuff rising um i know i have to
let you go but the oscars i've never
heard that before that's really funny
the oscars are in one week so we're
asking every oscar winner we see where
do you keep your oscar
uh
in storage
that's terrible but it's it's in a very
safe fireproof box while i travel and
we're asking anybody who's hosted before
any advice oh
you don't need it from me
[Music]